this Emoji is a total [ __ ] show Apple
completely butchered it and it's
actually kind of a big deal think I'm
being dramatic think again this is the
lotus flower it is a sacred symbol in a
lot of religions including Hinduism and
Buddhism and it has a deep history in a
lot of Asian cultures the Lotus
symbolizes Purity a beautiful unstained
flower rising from the mud here's
Apple's Emoji which looks nothing like a
Lotus more like a water lily which isn't
even in the same genus as the sacred
lotus lotus flowers grow on a stem above
the leaf not floating on the surface
like a damn Lily and I know Apple likes
their cute notches but lotuses don't
have Leaf notches like this this is a
different plant there is a water lily
that is called nymphia Lotus but it is
not sacred in Asia which matters because
searching Buddhism Hinduism or India on
Apple's keyboard brings up the Lotus
Emoji searching water lily doesn't
Google and other Emoji designers didn't
make this mistake so how on Earth did
this happen and who can connect me to
Tim Cook to get it fixed